The most characteristic feature of Euglena is its single long flagellum...
...which is used for locomotion.
it also has an organ for sensing light called the stigma or eye spot.
This enables the organism to orientate itself...
...so that it can obtain the optimum amount of light which it needs for photosynthesis.
This process is called positive phototaxis.
The chloroplasts and chlorophyll A and chlorophyll B in Euglena...
...are similar to those in plants.
However Euglena differs from plants in being motile and lacking a cellulose cell wall.
Instead, the shape of the cell is maintained to some extent by the pellicle.
A layer just outside the cell surface membrane.
Glucose is stored in the form of paramylon which is produced by the pyrenoid.
As in other protozoans,...
...the exchange of gases and the excretion of waste takes place via the plasma membrane...
...and osmoregulation is carried out by the contractile vacuoles.